this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer it was pi day
last month and call me an idiot for not
releasing this video then but I'm just
not a math nerd I'm an engineer and all
this hype for a mathematical constant
goes a little over my head
internet drama has been born out of
people for and against pi a quick search
of YouTube will yield tens literally
tens of videos teaching you how to
memorize the digits of pi the Guinness
world record for reciting PI with the
most digits as change hands multiple
times with the current champion Rajveer
mana of India managing 70,000 digits in
ten hours
Fairplay Rajveer fair play you've
finally made it now he can use the brain
for something actually useful jokes
aside this is a genuinely impressive act
of memory pi e is a fascinating
mathematical constant that defies any
tricks for memorization it just keeps
going and going and going
it just keeps going it's infinite and it
doesn't repeat itself so you just have
to brunt force memorize it and while
these lads are spending days learning as
many digits as possible mathematicians
are working away at calculating the new
longest string of digits pi is found
fairly simply by dividing a circle
circumference by its diameter so the
diameter of a circle can fit into its
circumference 3.14159265 three five
eight nine seven nine three two three
eight four six two six four three three
eight three two okay so you get the
point that is simple on paper but in
practice it is far more difficult
measuring a circle circumference
accurately is practically impossible
even your best attempts with a measuring
tape will be off by the thickness of the
measuring tape Archimedes was the first
to calculate pi with any level of
accuracy with an ingenious method called
the method of exhaustion and yes it's
nearly as exhausting as his videos
attempts at snarky humor he started
estimating Pi with squares which sounds
unconventional but it makes a lot of
sense in the mind of Archimedes a circle
was simply a polygon with an infinite
number of sides so by starting with a
polygon with fewer sides we can get a
rough estimate of Pi by calculating its
ratio of circumference to diameter let's
start by placing a square
site a circle with its corner is
touching the circle sites we can then
find the ratio of this low estimate of
Pi by dividing the sum of the square
sides by the diagonal diameter which in
this case is 2 point 8 to 8 this is our
low estimate of pi
now let's place a square with its sides
touching the circle side and this time
we will divide the sum of the square
sides by the length of one of the square
sites which gives us for the number of
sides the square has in both of these
cases we are dividing by the circles
diameter that figure is accurate what we
are lacking in accuracy is the
measurement of the circumference the
inside squares perimeter is too small
and the outside squares perimeter is too
big but now we know pi lies between
these two numbers now we just need to
narrow it down and we can do that by
increasing the number of sides of the
polygon each time we add a side those
figures will get more accurate and
eventually the two numbers will start
overlapping in their digits this is how
we got our first known digits of pi this
continued on for a couple of centuries
with mathematicians out exhausting each
other until eventually someone started
using computers and now we're just
exhausting them we now have two point
seven trillion digits of pi calculated
and for some reason through these
millennia an engineer never stood up and
yelled stop for the love of all that is
holy stop we have enough digits we don't
need anymore we don't have any circles
big enough to justify this level of
accuracy go to bed you lunatics because
in the end of the day that's what pi is
used for it's for calculating the
circumference and area of circles it's
for converting degrees to radians and
this's where the arts of mathematics and
engineering differ
while mathematicians obsess over
accuracy to the trilliant digit
engineers aimed for good enough and good
enough turns out to be 3.14159265 3 5 8
9 7 9 3 for the people that work with
the biggest circles nasa let's take the
distance to Voyager 1 which is currently
20 1.7 billion kilometres away in
interstellar space as our radius say we
want to calculate the circumference of a
circle with a radius dis large what
difference would adding 1 extra digit of
pi e provide that's the difference
between 15 decimal places and 16 decimal
place
this is actually tough enough to
calculate with a calculator or Excel as
both are limited in the number of
decimal places they can calculate too so
using this online high precision
calculator we can find that the
circumference of this circle will be
about a hundred and thirty six billion
kilometers and if we use one extra digit
it will be eight point six seven
millimeters closer to the actual value
that's tiny and we just traveled out of
the solar system
that's why JPL and NASA don't need any
more figures and the chances are you
don't need any more than 3.1416 so I'm
going to be that engineer that yell stop
please stop we have better things to be
worrying about pi is literally infinite
and we are never going to reach the end
what is the point if you don't want to
waste your life completing pointless
challenges you could try the challenges
on brilliant instead where they present
you with daily challenges that you can
solve with brilliance community
brilliant just released offline courses
on iOS so you can work on learning new
things even on an underground train or a
plane brilliant also recently released
their fantastic course on Python coding
called programming with Python Python is
one of the most widely used programming
languages and it is an excellent first
language for new programmers it can be
used for everything from video games to
data visualization to machine learning I
used it in my own master's thesis to
create custom plug-ins for my finite
element analysis software but I had to
teach it to myself and work through
constant errors this course will show
you how to use Python to create
intricate drawings coded messages and
beautiful data plots while teaching you
some essential core programming concepts
this is just one of many courses on
brilliant with more courses due to be
released soon on things like automotive
engineering if I've inspired you and you
want to educate yourself then go to
brilliant org 4 slash real engineering
and sign up for free and the first 500
people that go to that link will get 20%
off the annual premium subscription so
you can get full access to all their
courses as well as the entire daily
challenges archive as always thanks for
watching and thank you to all my patreon
support
if you'd like to see more from me the
links to my Instagram Twitter subreddit
and discord server are below
[Music]